in a flash
it happens clear not
really sure what why but
am i dead is this the afterlife
where's my body
[Music]
we all know we're not going to live
forever
[Music]
many cultures have strong beliefs about
death
and rituals that they practice but in
some places
we have more choices about what happens
to our bodies
after we die why is there so much demand
for body parts what options are there
for recycling our healthy usable parts
and how could it help the earth if we
recycled
our bodies this is what if
and here's what would happen if your
body could be recycled
[Music]
for many years people have been able to
choose to donate their
organs after they die this choice may be
listed on a driver's license
after death people can donate many body
parts
including their lungs heart pancreas
intestines corneas heart valves and
since 2014
hands and faces
healthy people donate organs while
they're alive
often to family members living donors
can spare
one kidney one lung a piece of liver
pancreas intestine or stem cells
unfortunately older organs can cause a
more powerful
immune response increasing the risk of
rejection but
that could change a new class of drugs
called
synalytics what targets and eliminates
old cells
recent studies in mice show that they
may help rejuvenate
older organs this could greatly increase
the supply of organs available for
transplant
and those organs are badly needed
in september 2020 there were more than
109
000 people on the u.s national
transplant waiting list
but only about 14 000 organs
are donated each year so
what does the future of body recycling
look like
well there are some really cool ways
that you can
currently and legally recycle your body
after death a company in the state of
washington called recompose
has developed a recomposition method to
compost bodies
in only one month it uses the beneficial
microbes that
naturally occur in the environment and
on our bodies
the body is put into a cradle with wood
chips
alfalfa and straw the cradle
is placed into a recomposed vessel and
covered with
more plant material for the next 30 days
the body and plant material stay in the
vessel
the microbes break everything down on
the molecular level
this produces three quarters of a cubic
meter of healthy
nutrient-dense soil it uses
87 percent less energy than cremation
and prevents one ton of carbon dioxide
from being released into the earth's
atmosphere
there's no need for a casket embalming
fluids or
more graveyards in one month a body is
turned
into healthy nutrient-rich soil
maybe instead of cemeteries we could
have composting
facilities with beautiful gardens
planted with
loved ones soil these plants would
undergo photosynthesis
producing oxygen and consuming carbon
dioxide
a greenhouse gas that's raising the
earth's temperature
so reducing the amount of carbon dioxide
would help the environment
and there are other ways we could
recycle bodies
did you know that a few ounces of
cremated remains can be used to make
human diamonds this process
uses heat pressure and carbon to create
a
diamond in six to nine months
human ashes can also be used in an
environmentally safe
cement mixture designed to create
artificial reef formations in the sea
this can create new habitats for fish
turtles and other life forms in the
ocean
or if you'd prefer to become a work of
art some companies can even mix
human ashes with tattoo ink and use it
to create
tattoos how we dispose of the dead has
a long history and it may take people a
long time to get
used to the idea of their loved ones
becoming soil
a precious stone or a tattoo
and with the advances in technology who
knows what the future may hold
maybe we could rule out dying altogether
and become cyborgs but
that's a story for another what if
you